in the lobby a financial piece Plaza
Kelly and Shana are with us welcome guys
how are you okay
welcome welcome where do you live we
live in Plano Texas Dallas area but very
different I'm the marketing director for
play now so Plano is its own unique got
it got it but it's a little bit north of
Dallas a little bit north well good to
have you guys welcome to Nashville thank
you and here to do your debt-free screen
yes sir how much have you paid off we
paid off a hundred and forty five
thousand way to go and how long did that
take six years four months okay very
cool making what kind of money during
that time well when we started out we
were making just under a hundred
thousand and when we wrapped it up we
were making a hundred and seventy five
combined cool and you're the marketing
director for Plano and what do you do
Kelli I'm gonna count it I work at
Phillips painting roofing and gutter
simply no good for you very cool
so a hundred and forty five thousand
what kind of debt was that it was all
our house paid off you're officially
weird that's right and in a hot real
estate market there's nothing better
than a paid-for house and I'm telling
you that feels good it does so that's
the that's the six years because you
were working baby step six not baby step
two that is very cool meanwhile you were
funding retirement and kids college if
that was a situation so tell me the
story tell me about your six-year
journey well it actually goes way back
before that a long before we knew who
you were we we got married we had about
$35,000 in debt and very quickly I
decided we are not gonna live this way
and had to fight about it we had a big
fight about it we're not gonna live this
way and so we actually did the debt
snowball before we knew what it was do
it common sense I thought you know
smaller yeah yeah okay so well you know
the funny thing is we came across your
curriculum at a Barnes & Nobles we're
walking around saw your book and I
picked it up and I started flipping
through it and I saw your debt snowball
and I was looking at it I was like this
is what I did I said this guy stole my
idea so I I thought well maybe there's a
little known fact that snowball from
Kelly
yeah well and I thought well maybe he
knows some other stuff so I've kept
looking at it and next thing you know
you know we're coordinators and Wow
yeah and so I'm actually coordinating up
my my job my boss Jason Phillips is
offered to pay for anyone to go through
a financial piece who's willing to go
through the whole course very cool so
I'm getting to do that and I've done it
in churches and everything it just it
makes a difference in people's lives it
really does and for us our journey like
I said we paid off our all of our other
debts got rid of our credit cards then
we found you and and so our plan kind of
started with let's get the house under
Dave's plan so we did the 15-year
mortgage and everything and it kind of
progressed from there and it was it just
went so fast because by that time we
learned how to live on a budget we knew
how to live within our means Wow and we
were fortunate that we bought our house
right as the real estate market was
really tanking you know in 2008 so we
were able to take advantage of the tax
credit for first-time homebuyers and we
used that that was right at the change
in the tax laws so we were able to roll
over our things into Roth's I mean it
just timing was wonderful what a timing
always seems to work out when you're
doing the right thing and that's right
yeah yes and then Kelly got frustrated
with us so we made his wife the Royal us
and so he had me create a debt free
chart because he felt like we were still
taking a really long time to pay off the
house you know six years four months
still felt like a long time so we had
paid for four years and four months and
we had paid off $60,000 in four years
and four months right we paid off the
remaining eighty five thousand and only
twenty three months after putting this
chart that charts powerful brushing your
teeth taking off your makeup looking at
the numbers this hung on the shower in
the bathroom on a glass you know and
every time I brush my teeth flossing
you're looking at this chart and you're
just angry because it's there and so I'm
pretty good at making money so at one
time we figured it up we were working
between the two of us five jobs I was
doing marketing consulting on the side I
was teaching at a university and then
you know meeting the right people at the
right time and really making a really
positive swing in my income moving just
kind of from corporation to corporation
even in the public sector you can you
can earn a good living
very cool very cool man so what's this
house worth with the real estate market
as it is in Plano and again marketing
director new corporate home for Toyota
how to throw down in there so our home
is now worth more than $100,000 over
what we paid for it six and a half years
would you pay for
we paid one hundred and eighty six and
$300,000 paid for house correct you're
making one hundred and seventy five
thousand you don't have a payment in the
world yeah how old are you
44 45 and 46 okay what is that well just
added HS we did need our notes for 45
the hard thing though that I think a lot
of people don't think about is the other
side of being debt-free I mean you know
I used to fantasize gosh you know when
we have not a payment in the world life
will be great but you have to still be
content and still live on a budget
because we postponed a lot of things you
know so we needed to immediately address
some foundation needs because we live in
a part of Texas where the foundation can
shift and so then that leads to you know
one thing after another so you find
yourself having to still as you voice
your budget and so we know we've really
worked on contentment issues and
contentment in the heart and it's easier
to do because we can shovel much more
quickly sure obviously but we're finding
that that snowball is still moving
although it's snowballing for things
that are really fun like renovation
projects instead of a house well in
helping others and your retirement your
investing is everything's no bad but
there's still plenty of things to do
with the money the like to get bored or
anything so how long have you all been
married almost 17 years is this the
first time you've been bit free since
you've been married no we've been
debt-free twice before because when we
paid off our debt originally right after
getting married we went overseas as
missionaries we thought that was going
to be permanent we came home
unexpectedly after two years and then we
again we weren't planning we didn't we
weren't ready so we came back and we
bought a car about nine thousand debt
pay that off quickly then discovered you
and we're never looking back I kind of
come up with a definition for debt in my
mind debt is is kind of the measurement
of
and the result of my lack of planning or
my lack of contentment with God's
provision oh that's pretty good I like
that one
very well done spoken like a good
Financial Peace University coordinator
now you better write that one down
because I might steal that too
Kelly and Shana from Plano Texas a
hundred and forty five thousand paid off
in six years that's their house and
everything they're weird a hundred and
seventy five thousand dollar income
counted down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
weird
I love that hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show I want to write a
song I want to own my own business I
want to make more money
those aren't goals those are wishes my
New Year's resolution is to make more
money this year to wish